[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue c'est un plaisir de vous
retrouver avec nos deux invités du jour
bon soit gabriel cluzel vous êtes
journaliste rédactrice en chef du site
boulevard voltaire
vous intervenez aussi régulièrement sur
ses news et vous êtes également
essayiste votre dernier livre engagé
nous sommes tous d enraciner pardon dans
l'engagement d'ailleurs mais en
l'occurrence enraciné nous sommes tous
des héritiers livre qui a été publié aux
éditions haere fais ça m'apprendra à
vouloir jouer les jeunes hommes et à ne
pas mettre mes lunettes
bonsoir parce que je venais sur
l'artiste président de l'association des
médecins urgentistes de france
vous êtes rattaché au samu de paris et à
l'hôpital necker pour être précis vous
avez passé la nuit dernière aux urgences
mais il ne regarde et vous avez l'air ça
ne se voit pas donc merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui
votre dernier livre urgence de vivre a
été publié aux éditions du cherche midi
il y avait aujourd'hui une manifestation
de policiers ils étaient plusieurs
dizaines de milliers alors 35 mille
selon la police mais alors est ce que la
police est aussi fiable quand elle le
compte ses propres rangs que pour des
manifestations de syndicats ne sais pas
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'ils
étaient nombreux les policiers à l'appel
de leur syndicat le ministre de
l'intérieur
est allée les saluer ce qui a fait quand
même beaucoup de bruit parce que c'était
une première et puis il y avait des
représentants de quasiment tous les
partis politiques
depuis le rassemblement national
jusqu'au parti communiste en passant par
les républicains et le patron du ps
une unanimité dont se félicite l'ancien
directeur général de la police nationale
aujourd'hui élu l air au conseil
régional d'île de france frédéric
péchenard mais pour soutenir les
policiers les policiers ne manque ni de
courage ni de volonté et manque de
soutien g c'est important qu'il sache
que la population française dial est
derrière eux et que les politiques les
élus locaux et parlementaires
l'ensemble des groupes politiques sont
derrière eux ce qui me paraît est une
bonne nouvelle est tout à fait
souhaitable
l'ensemble des groupes politiques tizi
frédéric péchenard et bien non car il y
en a un qui n'est pas du tout d'accord
avec cette initiative
c'est jean luc mélenchon le patron de la
france insoumise avait déjà indiqué
qu'il ne se joindrait pas à les
manifestations mais il a carrément
organisé une conférence de presse pour
expliquer tout le mal qu'il pensait de
cette initiative
regardez sous couvert d'un hommage au
policier tué une manifestation au
caractère ostensiblement factieux en ce
sens qu'elle s'en prend non pas aux
causes pour lesquelles ces malheureux
ont été assassinés mais aux institutions
comme l'institution judiciaire
les syndicats et les organisations
policières n'ont pas à faire la loi
qu'elle a exercées incroyable ce ton
cette virulence jean luc mélenchon parle
de chaos et de désordre organisé de
factieux qui injurie la justice est-ce
que c'est surprenant alors même que tous
les autres partis à l'exception quand
même d'une partie des écologistes
soutient les policiers on pensait que
toute la france soutenait la police en
réalité la france insoumise et quand
même un peu gêné aux entournures
avec évidemment c'est tout ce cette
manifestation autour de la poule
cette solidarité autour de la police
alors il faut quand même être tout le
monde soutient la police tout le monde
aime la police mais enfin le fait est
que tout le monde aime la police quand
il ya un drame c'est terrible à dire
mais vous savez moi je me souviens de ce
slogan de de l'ultra-gauche convoi tagué
sur certains murmurent aimons qu'on
trouve même sur des t-shirts en vente
libre à un bon flic est un flic mort
mais vous voyez cette phrase-là
finalement elle irrigue un peu la pensée
nationale parce que je remarque que ont
plein la police quand il ya un mort et
il faudrait arriver à un état d'esprit
où on soutient la police même quand elle
est active quand elle fait son boulot
voire parfois quand elle fait peur parce
que vous faire peur aux délinquants
c'est son rôle et là nous n'y sommes pas
du tout donc quand on dit tout le monde
aime la police non tout le monde l'a
soutien parfois comme la corde soutient
le pendu je rappelle que quand emmanuel
macron validé le concept de violences
policières chez brut
eh bien il la soutenaient pas et donc
quand il dit ensuite il faut soutenir la
police sans faille bien là il ya une
faille il a failli c'est lui c'est j'ose
dire
donc voyez cette unanimité elle est
quand même un peu fragile mais jean-luc
mélenchon évidemment c'est extrêmement
compliqué pour lui jean luc mélenchon
c'est celui qui défilent aux côtés d'axa
traoré 2 qui doit dans des
manifestations dans l'école on crie là
la police assassines
le racisme est systémique dans la police
et c'est donc évidemment c'était
compliqué pour lui de se joindre à cette
manifestation et ils auraient risqué à
tout le moins de se faire accueillir
peut-être assez fraîchement je rappelle
que la gérald darmanin est venu avec le
préfet de police mais il a été sifflé
moi je sors de la manifestation donc je
vous en parlais donc je pense que de ce
fait jean luc mélenchon a fortiori aux
rennes aurait été mal accueillie et là
il parle de factieux bien écouté il a
élé du côté de l'ordre cc c'est nouveau
ça vient de sortir
nous a déjà fait le coup je vous
rappelle avec la tribune des militaires
donc c'est important que jean luc
mélenchon met un peu de s'attaquer aux
factieux série qu'elle l'aide à
l'extrême gauche
on n'était pas habitué à ça patrick
leloup une fracturation supplémentaires
à l'intérieur de la gauche je vouvoyais
découvrir ces images et surtout ses mots
de jean luc mélenchon vous aviez l'air
effaré
oui parce que
avec la position positionnement de jean
luc mélenchon qui va être candidat à
l'élection présidentielle qui avait fait
un score honorable la guerre à la
dernière élection présidentielle il faut
avoir une stature d'état pourrions nous
rêver oui imaginez un état sans police
ça n'existe pas ça n'existe pas m ais
pourrions nous imaginer un pays sans
justice ça n'existe pas moi je peux je
pense que quand on est élu et
responsable au niveau de jean luc
mélenchon on doit rassembler et faire
que les systèmes fonctionnent mieux
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya des problèmes
et comme dans tous les systèmes ya des
problèmes il ya des problèmes et les
problèmes de formation et les problèmes
de moyens ce que ce conte ce qu'on voit
un peu dans tous les services publics
parce que nous avons un pays qui est
temps avec de grosses et qui va en avoir
encore plus après l'épisode du coc vide
des difficultés de financement des
services publics et donc il vaut mieux
être à mon avis solidaire de dire que
les policiers se comporte mal écouté la
pub faisait référence à mon travail je
travaille en fait quotidiennement avec
les forces de police sur paris c'est le
cas de tous les urgentistes en france on
a jamais de problème
moi je vois les effectifs de police
quand d'un coup il faut aller sauver
quelqu'un qui va qui risquent de mourir
ils y vont ils sont ils sont braves et
courageux
ce ne sont pas je ne me reconnais jamais
dans le discours rédhibitoire et et
méchant à l'agoa à l'égard de la police
par contre c'est vrai comme dans tous
les systèmes vous en avez qui sont pas
aptes à être policier qui sont
potentiellement violents et sert à la
police à des systèmes qui viennent de
réforme est d'ailleurs un que
l'inspection générale pour justement
faire attention à ce que ddd des
psychopathes ne devienne pas policier
s'en donne pas à coeur joie en faisant
du mal aux autres
bon voilà donc il ya une réflexion
globale et là ce qu'on voit enfin le
sentiment que j'ai eu ce qu en effet
vous avez vous tous les partis sont
venus à même des personnalités
importantes qui sont en lice pour
l'élection présidentielle comme anne
hidalgo
donc il ya un signe fort de la gauche
mais en fait la gauche est ultra divisée
sur ce sujet et on sent bien que la
réunion qui a eu il ya quelques semaines
disant que tout le monde allait être
unis pour faire une candidature unique
en fait c'est un rêve il n'y aura pas de
candidature unique à gauche aussi comme
vous livriez une expérience
personnel je me permets de vous poser
une autre question un peu personnel vous
n'êtes pas obligé d'y répondre mais vous
avez travaillé pendant de nombreuses
années pour charlie hebdo magazine
plutôt anarchiste on va dire dans son
état d'esprit dans liberté liberté page
archi ce que je voulais ajouter d'entrée
que néanmoins ou depuis les attentats
depuis l'attentât
et parce que vous avez des prises de
positions très courageuse sur
l'islamisme
vous avez une protection policière donc
vous voyez à quel point la police est
utile est-ce que du coup ça vous a fait
un peu changé d'état d'esprit
moi non parce que depuis avant même
d'aller d'être à charlie hebdo que j'ai
toujours travaillé même au cours de mes
études dans les services d'urgence et
les samu vous travaillez toujours avec
la police
donc moi j'ai déjà vu des policiers
risqué leur vie en allant chercher des
personnes qui étaient en train de brûler
dans les flammes j'ai déjà vu des
policiers se noue nous aider à
transporter des malades graves
j'ai déjà vu les exploits des motards de
la police quand on nous ouvre le
parcours dans des embouteillages mais
qu'ils risquent leur vie pour dégager le
passage des ambulances donc moi je les
vois alors oui certains diront oui mais
alors voilà il a le prisme des urgences
est un peu facile non non mais moi je je
je le vois comme ça et je vois bien en
effet j'ai un quotidien et je remercie
l'état de d'assurer ma protection
particulière à cause des menaces et
l'état le maître des policiers qui sont
toujours absolument exemplaire qu'ils
sont
voilà des jeux je crois écoutez si c'est
des vieux combats inutiles en fait des
pas dépasser le cas il ya un combat qui
prime
à l'heure actuelle en france c'est la
souveraineté du pays et l'emploi
voilà c'est comment réindustrialiser la
france ce n'est pas de monter les
françaises et français les uns contre
les autres ça voyez pourtant moi je suis
vraiment d'une culture de gauche mais
j'en peux plus en fait on a envie que ce
pays on le voit avec la crise on a envie
que ça fonctionne
or là ce qu'il se passe là c'est encore
de discréditer c'est en effet vous
citiez ce t-shirt comment on peut
laisser des t-shirts ou des
mmmmh dans des discours de chanteur rap
je n'écoute pas le rap mais j'ai rien
contre mais des discours de haine et de
conduite et d'appel au meurtre ce n'est
pas possible j'ai jeu et je vous le
redis quand d'un coup là ils ont fait
cette manifestation par rapport aux
policiers tués c'est une réalité ils
savent que quand ils vont travailler ils
risquent de mourir parce que maintenant
évidemment vous avez une montée en
puissance de la violence absolument
importante et l'islamisme vous parliez
de l'islamisme on sait très bien que les
islamistes
à l'heure actuelle leur objectif c'est
de tuer des policiers et des
personnalités ils ont ils ont raison ils
ont recentré leur objectif
mais c'est là dessus que le politique
doit doit se battre pas de diviser et or
là on a l'impression que la france
insoumise divise or la rhétorique pardon
si je peux me permettre de vous
complétez la rhétorique autour de
l'islamisme s'articule et bien
s'alimenter dans là aussi dans un
terreau anti-flics si j'ose dire je ne
sais pas si vous avez vérifié les les
les publications qui étaient consultés
par le terroriste de rambouillet mais
tout cela ça participe en fait du même
du même univers et donc c'est pour ça
c'est extrêmement dangereux et c'est de
la nitroglycérine à manipuler avec
beaucoup de précaution est ce qui
m'inquiète quand même fortement c'est
que la france insoumise
garde une grande ambiguïté sur tous ces
sujets violences policières moi j'ai
plusieurs fois demandé à une
personnalité de la france insoumise en
face de moi de venir mais est-ce que
vous condamnez les propos d'assad traoré
alors ils sont pas là pour défendre mais
néanmoins donc je les accuse
ils ne sont pas là mais le fait est
qu'ils ont toujours refusé refusé et ça
me dérange énormément mais je pense que
ils craignent pour leur électorat de
substitution qu'ils se sont choisis et
qui est qui et quand même le lymphome la
population issue de l'immigration et ils
ne veulent pas froisser ceux de suma
large suivi il ya en plus une volonté
réelle de déstabiliser notre pays et de
ses valeurs au niveau international on
le sait avec poutine c'est pour ça que
notamment contre la dernière élection
présidentielle hollande a dit il n'est
pas question de faire du vote
électronique parce qu'on sait très bien
ce qui s'est passé avec les états unis
mais avec l'élection de trump donc on
sait qu'on est attaqué on doit on doit
avoir un discours et or les islamistes
et c'est là où je retourne les
islamistes profitent justement de cette
haine flics pour déstabiliser notre pays
les internautes réagissent et nous vous
en remercions vous intervenez sur
youtube sur le site du figaro et puis
bien sûr sur le hashtag point de vue sur
twitter on vous réagissez notamment sur
la position du gouvernement nicole 06
considère que darmanin doit soutenir et
aider la police mais qui n'avait pas
être présent puisque il est lui-même en
responsabilité tandis que babineau
constate que dans ma main témoigne son
amour envers les policiers tandis que
dupont moretti rejette en bloc les
accusations de laxisme judiciaire et
puis ce point de vue de reinach par
idéologie ou par naïveté inexcusable à
gauche est à l'origine de la situation
actuelle est-ce que je peux me permettre
une parenthèse pour faire suite à ce que
vient de dire le ministre de la justice
qui m'a profondément gênés récemment à
propos de la sphère gisèle halimi où il
ya eu des manifestations disant que la
justice et l excision est juste rappeler
une chose
sara lee me sarr halimi pendant ce
rallye mais j'aurais juste rappeler une
chose c'est que en fait la personne qui
a été arrêté est pénalement rendu est
responsable elle ne sortira jamais de
d'un hôpital psychiatrique
faut juste savoir ça c'est que ça a été
oublié par tous les commentateurs c'est
que quelqu'un qui a été accusée comme ça
qui a commis un meurtre
il part en hôpital psychiatrique à haute
sûreté à haute
il n'y a aucun qui signera mais il y
restera parce que personne n'ira le
départ de nous pour ça de dire la
justice est laxiste
c'est pas tout à fait nous revenons à la
manifestation on vous pose la question
sur twitter le gouvernement en a t'il
fait assez pour la police et vous
répondez non à 72%
donc c'est un c'est une sondages mais
c'est quand même un questionnement gare
récuse elle vous le disiez vous revenez
de cette manifestation qu'elle était la
tonalité vous aviez le sentiment d'une
hostilité envers le gouvernement ou pas
spécialement
donc comme je vous le disais les les
membres du gouvernement enfin gérald
darmanin a été sifflé il n'est pas
arrivé du côté on l'attendait néanmoins
il a été sifflé mais j'allais dire que
c'était assez attendu c'est vrai que sa
présence était quand même un peu
curieuse parce que on se demande si
olivier ferrand va pas aller manifester
que le personnel hospitalier pour
demander des lits à ce train-là payer il
ya eu patrick il élève alors alors alors
il y en a maintenant papa noël
la grande et rosé on se dit bon personne
peut rien faire et et la boîte à livres
et vous voyez que je l ai quand on est
en responsabilité on assumera en
l'occurrence est pas allé au bout du
bout emmanuel macron peuvent être aussi
un gilet jaune est allé sur les ronds
points n'ont cessé je crois qu'il est il
n'était pas attendu la il a trouvé une
finesse politique mais c'était pas
forcément ce qui était le mieux nan moi
j'ai trouvé que la manifestation était
sereine
évidemment pas de violence d'un côté ni
de l'autre
c'était extrêmement calme mais en
revanche il y avait un grand sentiment
de ras-le-bol c'est évident c'est
évident et moi ce que je pense quand
même alors je veux pas vous agresser
mais je pense néanmoins que la gauche
depuis des dizaines d'années à saper
tous les fondements de l'autorité et
pour défendre manuel macron aujourd'hui
c'est là que mes mais il n'en est pas le
seul responsable
la police ont là-bas chez pendant des
dizaines d'années vous les autres le la
justice c'est quand même michel foucault
surveiller punir la prison c'est pas
bien il faut pas emprisonner tout ce
climat là même l'éducation nationale
interdire de il faut 20 voilà il est
interdit d'interdire pardon et tout ce
climat là aujourd'hui nous nous on nous
en payons la facture alors ça fait
peut-être un peu droite scrogneugneu de
dire ça mais pourtant néanmoins je pense
que c'est triste vérité
alors madame scrogneugneu jeu je crois
pas que la gauche en soit là je crois
pas que la gauche en soit là parce que
justement quand vous vous quand on
regarde les prises de position qui a eu
à gauche après les attentats 2015 ça a
été quand même assez très très fort je
vous rappelle que c'est donc françois
hollande
un président de la république qui avance
la déchéance de nationalité bon il n'a
pas été suivi justement par la gauche à
mon avis c'était une erreur mais ça n'a
pas suivi je crois pas qu'on puisse voir
les choses de manière aussi aussi simply
c'est sûr que l'on ne répond pas enfin
ce que l'erreur de la gauche a pas été
de croire à ces
et à la souveraineté du pays quand on
regarde c'est ce qui me titille 1 depuis
la crise du coc vide où on découvre
enfin les gens ont découvert les
journalistes ont découvert ce que nous
on savait depuis longtemps que 95 % du
matériel avec lequel on travaille à
l'hôpital vient de l'étranger on
s'éloigne encore un peu la souveraineté
tout est dans tout on exactement
réindustrialiser le pays on
réindustrialiser le pays vous donner des
emplois et là c'est là où j'ai une
certaine culture de gauche quand même là
dessus c'est de dire que si les gens ont
du travail c'est ça leur évitera de
faire des conneries merci voilà on a un
autre sujet qui est tout aussi
intéressant en tout cas j'espère à
traiter aujourd'hui il ya moins de
bêtises sur la planète mars vous savez
qu'on a lancé le déconfinement peut-être
faites-vous parler faites vous partie
des quelques millions de français qui
ont fait des selphy avec une tasse à
café sur la terrasse
et ben voilà patrick peloux retomber
dans tous les panneaux et puis
et le masque dans tout ça alors si vous
habitez la seine-et-marne
vous avez pu espérer pendant trois
heures hier que vous aviez pouvoir
enlever votre masque dans l'espace
public
la préfecture avait envoyé un tweet pour
dire ben voilà c'est d'autoriser à
condition qu'il ait pas trop de monde
mais ça c'était vers 15h et puis trois
heures plus tard changement de programme
n'ont finalement le masque est toujours
obligatoire petit cafouillage que le
ministre de l'intérieur a assumé ce
matin mise la santé nous avons considéré
hier que l'était encore trop tôt pour
alléger le port du masque
on a tous envie de revivre si j'ose dire
normalement en regardant le sourire des
gens que nous avons en face de nous nous
avons demandé effectivement préfet de
retirer leur autorisation
ce moment viendra il n'est pas encore
venu aujourd'hui c'est une grande
journée pour les français saluant pour
les restaurateurs que je voudrais saluer
de pouvoir retrouver un peu de liberté
avec la réouverture des terres sa
journée en terrasse et masqués va vous
prenez votre café j'imagine sans masque
madame salamé gfa vous l'avez vu il faut
leur mettre effectivement faut-il mettre
fin aux masques alors dû déconfinement
ben c'est l'égalité parfaite sur twitter
en revanche il ya une majorité claire
pour le oui sur youtube à 70%
bon alors docteur peut louer est-ce
qu'il faut qu'on garde le masque à
l'extérieur ou pas ou alors il se sert à
rien non non ça sert sa serre ça sert ça
sert si on à limiter l'épidémie a
pendant un arbre à pain attend à voir
avant que ça s'excite sur les machins
sociaux
je suis à fond pour le déconfinement
d'accord il faut que la société
repartent
je les perds mais juste une parenthèse
sans partir ailleurs juste de dire qu'en
fait on n'a rien fait d'autre que de
gérer une crise hospitalière d'accord
n'oubliez jamais ça mon à gérer une
crise hospitalière bon donc du coup là
maintenant on en est ou de l'épidémie
soit dit en passant la prise de position
du gouvernement et du président de la
république était juste
ils ont bien fait de ne pas écouter un
certain nombre de grands professeurs qui
disait qu'il fallait avoir un
confinement strict et total pendant
trois mois
donc il ya une politique qui a été fait
il faut la saluer qui a été courageuse
ambitieuse et qui a fonctionné puisque
tous les chiffres se casse la figure
comme vous le disiez je travaillais
cette nuit on a eu peut-être 2,4
qu'ovide sur paris voilà donc sa baisse
bon le problème qu'il ya c'est que le
virus
on sait pas trop où on va alors j'ai
entendu la déclaration d'olivier vers en
disant en gros on peut espérer qu'on que
tout s'arrête à l'automne c'est pas sûr
parce qu'il va y avoir encore des
mutants il va y avoir encore ce virus
qui va évoluer et on sait pas où ça va
aller est ce qu'on ne sait pas si les
vaccins qu'on va avoir seront valables
et là on peut pas enlever le masque tant
qu'on ne dépasse pas 40 à 50 % de la
population vaccinée
on en est loin je le regrette encore la
vaccination se passe à mon avis et c'est
vraiment encore une vitesse d'escargot
mais bon soit on garde le masque mais la
question du sahara est ce qu'il faut
garder le masque
partout c'est à dire est-ce que d'une
région à l'autre d'un environnement à
l'autre
si vous êtes en train de faire une
randonnée dans le vercors sont peut être
pas indispensable qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
oui de fait le masque aurait quand même
été l'objet symbolique de ces crises je
pense qu'on l'a représentera on montrera
le masque c'est le masque c'est un objet
des tragédies grecques mêlant
l'occurrence ccc il aura eu la même
fonction ici au début alors début il
était
inutile voire nuisible parce que quand
on le mettait comme ça dans la rue on le
prenait au personnalise pitallier qui
lui en avait vraiment besoin puis après
il est devenu obligatoire et on a été
sanctionné pour ne pas le porter je
rappelle d'ailleurs ça nous ramène au
sujet précédent qu'il ya un certain
nombre de gens qui ont quand même mal
vécu d'être verbalisés pour un port du
masque sous le nez et je pense que ça va
pas fait du bien pour les relations
entre les français et la police parce
qu'on a eu ce sentiment ça il y en a qui
conceptualise ça sous le nom de anarcho
tyrannie c'est à dire qu'on est dur avec
les gentils est faible avec les méchants
c'est à dire que pendant que ça brûle et
qu'il y avait des ddd dans les banlieues
pour faire court et bien les madame tout
le monde se faisait verbaliser le savez
de l'amande sais c'est c'est le péché
des gens ordinaires qui font pas grand
chose s faisait verbalisée parce qu'elle
avait son masque sous le nez c'était le
péché de la france bien élevé si j'ose
dire et donc donc ce max un véritable
enjeu en plus en plus il fait pas partie
de nos civilité il faut bien le dire
jusqu'à des locaux vides
on voyait arriver les chinois avec leurs
masques en france de certains de leurs
bus on se disait franchement non ccc ccc
pas nous on nous dit aussi que les
enfants à la crèche ont du mal à
apprendre à parler on voit bien coin
dans les relations humaines c'est très
mauvais donc c'est vraiment le ce masque
il n'est pas un détail on nous dit oui
il faut le mettre alors quelques fois on
n'a pas de justification
il faut le mettre parce que c'est si
vous l'enlevez vous allez vous
déshabituer voyez l'argument vous avez
vous des habitués à le mettre en
intérieur si vous mélangez en extérieur
c'est comme si moi on me disait le matin
si vous enlevez votre pyjama besoin de
lire et de le mettre ce soir c'est ça
quelque chose d'assez de voiliers
d'ubuesque on sent bien qu'il ya pas de
fondement scientifique complet par
ailleurs et je termine à dessus
guillaume roquette a absolument raison
c'est à dire que tout unifié nessma j'ai
c'est toujours bien d'être bien avec le
présentateur et c'est comme ça que vous
avez fait votre carrière
ouattara
[Rires]
et de ce fait c'est ridicule 2 comment
dire de faire la même loi pour tous
évidemment au fond de l'aveyron et à
l'aubrac et sur les champs elysées je la
fais la même population
évidemment évidemment ça a été l'erreur
du premier confinement ou en mars on
avait figé toute la france et on a eu
très peu de cas on ne sait toujours pas
pourquoi mais très peu de cas en
bretagne bon mais c'est comme ça il y
avait il faut un moment prendre une
direction politique il fallait que ça
fonctionne
leleu les arguments que vous venez de
donner c'est exactement les arguments
qui a été donné par les contradicteurs
pour le port du masque au mois de
juillet d'accord où on se disait il faut
rendre de masques partout j'avais eu
plaisir d'en débattre avec le premier
ministre et moi je vais dire en effet
j'avais pris cet argument de dire un
legros kloster qui avait eu en italie
c'était un marathon en plein air
d'accord et c'était parti comme ça la
réunion des évangélistes sur mulhouse
elle était quand même sous des tentes en
plein air ça a fait un peu steurs donc
il ya bien une réalité
ce casque on a cherché ça a été de
casser la transmission le plus
rapidement possible et le port du masque
à donner à mon sens de de bons résultats
là maintenant je pense que cette mesure
commence à être usé mais on est obligé
de le garder tant qu'on n'aura pas
vacciner tout le monde qu'est-ce qui se
passerait revint si on enlève le masque
et si on dit et je comprends
complètement parce que moi comme vous
comme ceux qui nous regardent j'en ai
ras-le-bol de ce truc là d'accord
qu'est-ce qui se passerait si on enlève
les masques d'accous on va dire après le
gel le gel c'est pas grave puis on revit
normalement mais vous avez un virus qui
est là qui peut qui demande qu'une chose
c'est reparti heureux développé il ya
des on a dit à d'incertitude à regarder
ce qui se passe en angleterre ou d'un
coup les variants sont arrivés et
l'astra zeneca semble pas si bien
fonctionné que ça sur les variants cdta
d'interpellations est on est on a une
belle heure éclaircies on a une belle
embellie
moi je suis en effet je suis allé boire
le café ce matin et j'étais très heureux
de retrouver
mon café etc mais il faut absolument se
dire que potentiellement parce que là la
crise de l'hôpital elle est toujours
réelle et je fais partie de ceux qui
disent que toute façon tout va redevenir
comme avant avec la sanction
supplémentaire pour le système de santé
qu'il va falloir rembourser le déficit
abyssal de la sécurité sociale qui se
sont creusés pendant cette crise je vous
livre les commentaires des internautes
moonlight qui consultent à qu'il faut
supprimer le masque à l'extérieur sans
aucun doute en revanche est quand même
il est pour le conserver à l'intérieur
le masque à l'extérieur c'est le
principe de précaution maximale 10
babineau la distanciation physique est
une alternative et nathan 770 qui lui ça
fait bien longtemps que je ne mets plus
le masque à l'extérieur alors justement
la distanciation physique parlons-en
vous avez peut-être cet article amusant
du canard enchaîné qui est s'est
renseigné dans un certain nombre de
musées pour savoir quelle était la
distance qui était demandé entre les
visiteurs et alors là non plus ses
parents une science exacte parce que si
vous allez au musée d'orsay vous n'avez
pas le droit d'être à moins de deux
mètres de votre voisin si vous descendez
à marseille
le mucem c'est un mètre cinquante alors
on dira c'est le laxisme des
méditerranéens et ben non parce qu'au
centre pompidou c'est plutôt un m il ya
des règles ou bien c'est tout ça est
complètement typhon nesat est celle où
ces pifométrique y en a il y en a qui
ont fait d'aider des études avec des
projections de postillons alors après
c'est ça ne s'arrêtait pas cohérent
parce qu'il fallait mesurer en fonction
du vent cesser ces quelques lignes donc
on voit bien que c'est
c'est vrai comme simple mais c'est juste
des c'est une ligne politique pour
prenons le code de la route
évidemment dans un monde idéal tout le
monde respecterait loti aurait pas
besoin de signalisation de code de la
route etc
on a été obligé d'en fait rare parce que
c'était une anarchie là il ya une
direction de politique de santé de santé
publique ça a été dire bon ben voilà il
faut se laver les mains
souvenez vous il y avait quasiment aucun
aucune toilettes dans beaucoup de
restaurants ou qui était propre où il y
avait du savon bon ben voilà on a
progressé là-dessus on a progressé et la
transmission orale parce que c'est ça le
problème du corps de lakovic 19
il fallait l'endiguer c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont eu raison et qu'il faut
encore tenir le masque
notre seule défense je le redis da c'est
la vaccination
voilà ce qui manquait un petit peu c'est
que j'ai l'impression que quand ça va
mal on nous dit ça va mal donc il faut
mettre le masque et quand ça va mieux ou
le masque ou où toutes les distances de
sécurité les jauges etc
laver les mains jeu mais sa part parce
que j'ai envie de dire que c'était c'est
presque ancestrale cc.oo décennaux au
mans mais me nommer ici mon père qui est
un mec est un médecin d'un certain âge
me disait de nombreuses années on a
oublié de se laver les mains c'est
l'arrivée des antibiotiques etc
les gens ont bien l'action communale
dans les hôpitaux été transmise par le
man ray ou la passionnante du littoral
mais ça veut dire c'est revenir à un
temps où les médecins vite et des blues
se laver les mains qui a été peut-être
oublié donc moi je trouve ça tout à fait
ça le masque c'est autre chose la
distance physique c'est autre chose et
maintenant lorsque ça va bien on nous
dit ah oui mais ça pourrait aller mal
donc il faut que vous continuiez à faire
ce que vous faites donc nordique sa
vraie nommant un nom sortiront non salée
quand retrouverons nous des mercenaires
alors à cernier mot patrick pleau ce
camp va en sortir
on n'en sait rien quand on est quand on
écoute les historiens d épidémiologie et
les virologues ils disent en gros le
temps que ce coronavirus cesse il
faudrait peut-être six années alors
évidemment on va pas vivre six années
comme ça c'est pas possible
donc il faut qu'on trouve un curseur
vous avez raison d'adaptabilité pour
dire voilà qu est ce qu on fait comment
on fait
déconfinement ou d où des restrictions
très ponctuel de tel ou tel endroit
il faut il faut voir ça mais là à
l'heure actuelle on est encore sur une
culture de masse pour pas que ça reparte
si voilà merci à patrick pelloux le
débat fait rage aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux avec des prises de positions qui
sont très différentes c'est passionnant
nicolas par exemple nous dit il faut
arrêter avec cette mascarade
utile ou pas utile de masquer ce n'est
même pas la question les gens sont
terrorisés maintenant dès que quelqu'un
tousse et on a flingué une génération de
jeunes ados bien pour tous ceux que ce
sujet intéresse je me permets de faire
la promotion d'un excellent magazine le
figmag sera demain matin dans les
kiosques il sera dès ce soir sur le site
du figaro on a eu envie de faire le
point
c'était un peu l'heure des comptes avec
le déconfinement est ce qu'on en a trop
fait est-ce qu'on a pris les bonnes
décisions
il ya d'un côté les critiques parfois
virulentes de médecins aussi connu que
le professeur peron professeur raout
martin blachier ou patrick peloux qui
nous a fait l'amitié de participer à ce
dossier avait puis comme il n'est de bon
débat que contradictoires le ministre de
la santé olivier verront répond point
par point à toutes ces critiques ou
accusations merci beaucoup à tous les
deux merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
et à demain